the URL is Sabian symbols.com
forward slash the dash Oracle
and it's s-a-b-i-a-n
what's next I'm really liking how
Dynamic this story is and how
it's it's loaded with possibility in in
a really fun way
and it made me curious
uh
there's this
thing that's similar to like a tarot
reading that's called the Sabian Oracle
that works with the Sabian symbols
um
and you get like a little mini reading
from it
uh it was somebody who sat down in the
19 an astrologer sat down in the 1920s
with a psychic and held up 360 cards one
degrees two degrees and she saw
an image for each one and he recorded
them
so you like focus on a question
trigger it it's the same thing in Tarot
you think about a question and then pick
some cards
and you get some kind of reading from it
and this is not something I'm into
it's I do it a few times a year out of
curiosity sometimes it's not worth much
sometimes it's really interesting
and so just for a story that's this kind
of partially formed
with a lot of interesting potential
I thought it would be just curious to
see what
uh
what comes up for it wonderful
so
so really I just want to like Focus for
a minute on what I'm actually
questioning
this would be the intention of your
story
the protagonist's journey it's more like
a question
and like so as I'm
focusing I'm finding myself in the
position of the Android like I'm being
the robot
and kind of like
looking at the world that now confronts
me probably the Sun
and in my confusion about the
contradictory elements
it's almost like you know what
is this
I'm not sure if
I'm not sure if I'm vocalizing it right
but almost like
what is this story about
and I'm seeing it from the point of view
of this like confused robot
the site is what is the URL of the
website okay so here's what it said
a nature spirit dancing in the midst of
a waterfall
that's what this psychic that's the
image she saw a nature spirit dancing in
the midst of the waterfall and then
there's like an interpretation so I'm
just the image doesn't do a lot for me
right away but I'm curious the paragraph
below it what that says
it says this symbol shows skipping
lightly over the surface of Life dancing
and playing
you may feel emotionally light and
almost mischievous the worries of life
and the deeper parts of your feelings
are ignored as you effortlessly flit
over the surface of any troubles
whilst this is essentially a beautiful
symbol of Joy Harmony and a lightness of
being there may be an element of feeling
cut off from your body or reality
this can lead to a sense of alienation
or difficulty in knowing where to land
or evading Problems by ignoring them or
Rising above them
effervescent Spirits dancing in a
Carefree manner water and fun Peter Pan
attitudes celebrations of the natural
world waterfalls Mist nymphs fairies
subtle Energies
irresponsibility the avoidance of real
situations not taking anything seriously
escapism moving or flying around
perceptions of light fear of dark places
naive
so that's interesting
in terms of this robot and and what's
interesting about it is
we talked about the sun corrupting the
operating system of this
kind of like Super Robot
for lack of a better word
um
and
we talked about like
seeing Spock like on catnip where he's
like rolling around on the floor
laughing and
like this reminds me of that and it kind
of amplifies that aspect
of this story in an interesting way in
other words it's just a what if it's
it's kind of like the 36 dramatic
situations like I'm looking at ambition
and it triggers a lot of possibilities
as I'm looking at this like the image
itself a nature spirit dancing in the
midst of a waterfall I was like I don't
know what that means didn't really like
grab me but the explanation is great
um
feeling emotionally light and almost
mischievous that's an interesting word
the worries of life and deeper parts of
your feelings are ignored as you
effortlessly flit over the surface of
any troubles it's almost like this the
sun has like
gotten them high on crack or something
like he's like this robot that's usually
like that's not logical we shouldn't do
that like really organized efficient on
top of things all of a sudden like I
want to look at the little birdie and
can we wrestle you know it's like
just kind of
deliberately like had a wire snipped by
the new owner
to make it more malleable and yet it's
also
plays into
um well it talks about the element it
says well this is essentially a
beautiful symbol of Joy Harmony and a
lightness of being there may be an
element of feeling cut off from your
body or reality
which is
interesting for a robot
cut off from reality is one thing cut
off from your body is another but it
really is like a personality change
and yet it seems great like you're
happier
you don't care about logic anymore you
know like Spock wants to play the guitar
instead of you know do Quantum
calculations or something
Um this can lead to a sense of
alienation or difficulty in knowing
where to land
see that's the thing of like
I used to be super clear about ethics
and how to navigate certain types of
things and now I'm like
it reminds me of the
what was it um
the the killer robot movie from years
ago
um
RoboCop
and uh at one point toward the end of
the movie The RoboCop is trying to go
down a set of stairs but it can't do
stairs the way and it comes up to the
and it's like toes are like trying to
like it's trying to like how do you do
this like it and it fell down the stairs
well the idea of like trying to
difficulty in knowing where to land like
how do I navigate this terrain it's
foreign to me now that
I feel more giddy or
like the robot's gonna think this has
been a great upgrade in his system but
it really it's like snipped a wire
and
made him happier and looser which is
desirable
from his point of view because he wants
to be human it's like data learning how
to laugh and yet it's also like
this is kind of scary I feel out of
sorts I don't know what's real
um
effervescent Spirits dancing and
carefree manner water and fun remember
we kept talking about the beach and
being a good Surfer Peter Pan attitudes
it's it's interesting it's like the sun
could really have
sort of gotten him high
you know what I mean and it's he's like
this is fun I can surf the girls like me
you know it's like
I ate a hot dog today
it's tempting
and it's not just tempting it's
gratifying and it's also
discombobulating if that's the right
word like the lack of judgment
but it's liberating I mean that's it and
it see how it fits in with the Dilemma
like I can't let go of this because it's
creating me it's the best thing that
ever happened to me and I can't keep
doing this because I don't trust it I
feel manipulated part of me is like
screaming that this is all wrong and the
art other part of me is like let's smoke
more crack this is great you know so
it's like
but I know that smoking the crack is bad
but
I need I'm starving for that human
capacity
and then the negative aspect of it is
irresponsible irresponsibility avoidance
of real situations not taking anything
seriously escapism
naivete
so that was just like a fun Venture but
it really
suggested
a highly specific way that the sun could
corrupt the operating system
and
it's a reward system
it's a you know it's
experiencing some of the joys of being
human
in a way that's irresistible
and yet also
and it's very much wish granting
here's your wish of becoming a real boy
you know and be careful you know if yeah
you get all your wishes but things go
wrong too in this type of story
but that was that was an interest ing
what if
did you type in a question no okay I
just thought about it you just and then
just hit this button and then it brings
this up but I was focused you could see
me Focus for a minute like I'm the robot
I'm like what
how do I deal with this and like what's
this story about of this robot trying to
figure out how to deal with this and
that just popped up
and I probably won't even think about
this for another six months like it's
not part of my normal thing at all